political advertising you may have seen
this new online ad from missouri u.s
senate candidate eric greitens take a
look it shows the former gop governor
holding a gun and supposedly hunting
moderates in his own party calling them
rhinos that would mean republicans in
name only
facebook has banned the ad and twitter
flagged it for abusive behavior but
guess what if his campaign was to buy
commercial advertising slots on local tv
an industry expert tells us that cbs
news stations would have to air it and
that is for sure true when it comes to
lies several candidates in other states
have already used tv ads to repeat false
claims of fraud in the 2020 election
and now you might think that broadcast
stations like this one could reject such
outright lies but in fact we have no
choice but to air them no matter how
blatant or misleading be advised
the liberal pro-biden pro-china wall
street insider every election year it
seems like politicians hit us with a
one-two combination of spin alex movie
repeatedly disrespects veterans and
scorn reckless dangerous and
irresponsible it's all part of a long
tradition of using the public airways to
persuade and you might even say
manipulate american voters
[Music]
but while you're regular everyday
commercial advertisers can sometimes
face allegations of stretching the truth
you'll get the best 5g network they're
at least required by federal law to back
up their claims with facts
you should know those rules do not apply
to political candidates don't assume
that the political ad that you hear
contains true information joseph watson
guided the george w bush administration
on telecommunications policy and is now
a professor at the university of georgia
so a serial company can't lie about
their serial but a candidate can lie
about their politics that is absolutely
true and lately he says the lying has
gotten both bolder and more frequent it
has not been historically as much of a
problem prior to 2016. i would say after
2016 the world has changed a lot watson
points to commercials like this one from
president biden's 2020 campaign if trump
gets his way
social security benefits will run out in
just three years from now it earned four
pinocchios from the washington post fact
checker a rating reserved for whoppers
the thought of americans who are living
on fixed incomes thinking that's going
to go away is terrifying yeah and here
we have that lie approved by joe biden
absolutely yeah but of course not all
lies are created equal and this election
cycle there's one lie above all the
others we won by a lot not just a little
bit
a lie that stands out in terms of sheer
repetition blue state liberals stole the
election from president trump i'll make
sure our elections are never stolen
again the amount of misinformation we're
seeing in a midterm cycle
is more than i've seen
in the past in a presidential election
cycle that's what concerns me about 2024
if this is what the midterm looks like
and the ads are this aggressive and
contains so much misinformation
what is it going to look like in the
2024 presidential cycle so why you may
fairly ask with television stations air
campaign commercials we know to be wrong
if you're watching this ad right now it
means you're in the middle of watching a
fake news program the answer is we must
and if you don't believe me here's bill
whittle who oversees advertising for our
affiliate wfsb in hartford connecticut
have you ever rejected a political ad
no i haven't
and how many years
20. he showed us how he reviews ads from
political candidates this is where i
watch the spot to make sure that it
conforms to the rules and regulations we
notice there is an option to reject the
commercials but not for lying they have
to say it's paid for by the candidate
has to use their name and it has to be
on the screen
for at least four seconds everything
else fair game pretty much the rules
were set almost 90 years ago by a law
that states broadcasters have no power
of censorship over any legally qualified
candidate for office
and it requires stations to offer their
lowest available rates ahead of an
election
is it ever frustrating knowing that you
have to press play on an ad that you has
falsehoods in it yes yes it is
definitely does that cause any trouble
for the station you get phone calls
about it we get a ton of calls two
one
and take it in addition to accepting
candidate ads broadcasters must run them
without edits
although as watson sees it there is
maybe one potential option for stations
interested in flagging ads from
candidates they could put a disclaimer
at the start of an ad that might say you
know the following is a paid political
advertisement that may contain
information that's not been verified or
validated um there should be no
preclusion to do that but the the
challenge for broadcasters is any
disclaimers that they put at the at the
start of an ad can't be paid for by the
candidate i don't see them doing that no
what about uh allowing media companies
like cbs and the other big broadcasters
to step in and reject ads that are false
who watches the watchmen
who watches us you mean
so if you empower a government body to
police the truth that's problematic
if you empower media companies to step
in and filter the ads
that's problematic
and so we're left with what we have
that's exactly right there really are no
easy solutions
to resolving this issue and that's why
it's such a conundrum
no easy solutions people are only
restrained by their own sense of shame
and we should mention that 1934 law
applies only to broadcasters on public
airwaves so not cable networks not
social media companies they are free to
remove or reject misleading political
content i want to do this piece because
i hear from people online of course who
are saying how dare cbs air that ad you
know there are lies in it we don't have
any choice it's the law this is
fascinating it doesn't make any sense it
doesn't make sense and it's eye opening
but i have a couple of questions one who
watches the watchmen yeah and and i
might be asking myself that looking in
the mirror reflection but then this
communications act of 1934 has there
been efforts to change it and is there a
slippery slope if you do how do you
determine what's a lie isn't that the
big question the only option i think
would be to take the political law from
34 and apply it to cable and online
which would just increase the platforms
for ads uh it would mean that everybody
has to accept everything the tragedy and
the triumph of america is that there is
no ultimate backstop to preventing
political lies except for the american
people yeah but the candidates one
another but tony the candidates know
they're putting on stuff that lo that
that is a lie so when they say my name
is tony decouple and i approve this ad
that means that that means proved it
they've approved the lie they contain it
they put their name on it they put their
name on it it's the only requirement and
they used to be restrained by shame but
shame is something from the old days
apparently yeah shame doesn't sound good
it's not a deterrent anymore